Russian fighter jets seem to have
collided with a U.S unmanned aircraft
system a U.S drone over the Black Sea in
international waters two Russian su-27
aircraft the Americans are saying
conducted what they call an unsafe and
unprofessional intercept with a U.S Air
Force drone MQ-9 unmanned aircraft they
say one of the Jets clipped uh the Drone
they were forced to bring it down what
do you make of all this
well it's interesting why doesn't it
because I did sort of suggests an
accident but it appears from Air Force
command that actually they're doing
their best uh to bring that drone down
and they've been carrying out Maneuvers
for a short while before they actually
uh clipped it and flipped it down
um I think it is a provocation I'd say
that the Russians do have form for this
um around the Black Sea but in other
areas as well of what are described as
extremely uh doers I mean it really does
ramp things up doesn't it if they start
to actually to engage
um with the Russian as with the American
forces and European uh fighter jets as
well at the moment that isn't the case
this is a drone they possibly consider
that something like fair game though it
was in international water so it is
allowed uh to happen a provocation for
certain will it be interesting to see uh
where where it develops I think the
Russians would say that the provocation
has also come from the United States and
uh the Western allies who are supporting
Ukraine and Russia has obviously been
angry about that and made those sort of
claims before so it's one of those
things that does happen I say the
Russians do have form for this type of
thing but it just ramps it up and it
just makes this terrible situation even
more dangerous I suspect